even as a small kid all you ever wanted
was to climb your little toes dangle off
the edge of the wooden frame of your
bunk bed your action figures are down
below on the carpet looking as small as
ants seeing the world from this height
is an adrenaline rush like no other but
soon you outgrow your bunk bed and you
return to the level the rest of the
world is living on to recapture the
feeling you ride your bike to the park
where you climb the tallest slide and
sit perched at its peak the feeling of
the bunk bed comes back to you appear
you're closer to the stars and further
from your homework you think i'm never
going back down but soon there is a line
of children on the slide's ladder
barking at you calling you a scaredy cat
telling you to hurry up already a hand
presses into your back and pushes you
forward your small body tumbles down the
slide just like that your feet are in
the sand you're at the same altitude as
everyone else no longer special in your
elevation but you're not done you're
determined to go elsewhere and upward
you start climbing trees first just
small ones with bumpy bark for your feet
to use like rungs on a ladder it feels
good up there but soon you notice you're
not alone you're sharing the space with
squirrels and caterpillars it's not that
you're afraid of these little creatures
but you want to go to a height few else
ever had you move on to a larger tree
this one you even need tools to climb
you lasso a rope around a branch and
pull yourself up to get even higher you
wear wide receiver gloves banned by the
nfl so that your hands are sticky enough
to grip even the smallest protrusions
apart
soon you reach the top now at the
highest sturdy branch of the largest
tree you look down at the world and see
it in perfect order you appear
them down there it is beautiful but then
a noise a noise too loud to have come
from below next to you see a bird it
smugly smirks at you and flaps its wings
and flies higher one upping your
accomplishment it lands on a tiny branch
above you reaching the actual tippy top
that you couldn't reach and it's then
you realize that the feeling you're
chasing isn't just so that you can look
down on the earth and scoff but so you
can look up at the world and wonder so
you spend your life with your chin to
the sky feet following your gaze
everything you do every action you take
is in the name of elevation you chose a
career in being a union line man you
work the night shifts climbing up
telephone poles your happiest farthest
from the ground every november you
vacation to new york where you run up
the empire state building just to taste
new heights you summit 86 flights
1576 stairs but no matter what extremes
you go to you feel like there is
something up there still out of reach
waiting for you there is only one thing
that will satisfy you mount everest if
you can just reach the summit you
promise yourself your wife your god and
your family that you'll stop straining
your neck upward that you'll enjoy what
is in plain sight that you'll settle
down and live the life that's right
there in front of you you begin to study
for your two-month climb you learn about
the sub-zero temperatures you learn
about the journey's physical demands on
your body you learn about navigation
communication and preparation but what
you don't learn about or rather can't
learn about is the anomaly that awaits
you unfortunately some lessons are
omitted from books left to be learned
only by experience and by that time i'm
afraid it'll be much too late in the
lecture to get a passing grade the day
comes and you begin your mission to the
mountain's peak there's something
otherworldly about it the way you move
up this mountain it isn't just a matter
of labor there's a spirituality within
the journey you feel as if you're
floating being pushed toward the heavens
by some generous being behind you but
what is it that actually pushes you
upward could it be as simple an answer
as will power determination skill no
you've felt those before and while they
have surely powered many men to do great
things this force is different it is not
so much that it is pushing you forward
it is more like it is pulling you up or
rather luring you in you're amazed at
how effortless the journey is at least
it is up until now upon reaching the 8
000 meter mark also known as the death
zone you begin to feel uneasy no longer
is each step light and graceful now it
feels like your boots are filled with
cement you could swear your backpack is
full of bricks for a moment you think
you have lost your beanie and gloves
because your ears and fingers are ice
cold the journey suddenly becomes long
and grueling dangerous and difficult you
use every muscle in your body to climb
this thing you have to you use every bit
of mental concentration just to keep
moving you have to but why
why now could it be as simple an answer
as exhaustion accumulated fatigue how
could it be you've prepared as much as
humanly possible not just in your
training but in your life you were meant
for this moment but now the moment is
refusing your embrace nothing you could
have done could have prepared you for
this an amorphous feeling settles into
your gut you don't understand it
entirely but you anticipate something
bad is about to happen and it is at this
moment that you wish you wouldn't have
traveled alone you wish you had a
partner to reassure you that everything
would be okay you wish you had someone a
few steps in front encouraging you
forward you stop and stare ahead and
imagine it you imagine a friend to
struggle with to laugh with to succeed
with and then suddenly you don't have to
imagine any longer you see someone but
how last you heard you were the only one
to be traveling this way could it be an
illusion you squint harder and harder
trying to make sense of what you're
actually seeing a human or at least a
human-like thing it is wearing all white
mountaineering clothes and boots there
is something about the clothes and boots
that makes you think they might not even
be clothes or boots at all but more like
an extension of flesh although they
appear to be made of traditional
clothing materials they seem to be one
with the figure's body and the figure's
body seems to be one with the mountain
while you are on a mountain thousands of
miles away from your family this
thing
is at home but what is it you squint
through specks of snow splashing across
your vision it seems about average human
height and average human weight could it
be simply an average sized human you
want to make this conclusion with your
mind but your eyes won't let you at this
distance it is still just a figure but
as he approaches you and the possibility
of a companion sinks in you become more
optimistic and you think maybe this
figure can be a friend little do you
know you have just met a mountain
climber's biggest foe meet scp-1529
you notice it's black goggles and then
strangely enough you can't stop noticing
them you find it impossible to break eye
contact with you are physically unable
to turn away not only that but you do
not have any desire to turn away either
you are drawn into its gaze and you are
happy to be there for the first time in
your entire life you are content with
where you are at you no longer care
about climbing mount everest you strive
no longer for great physical or
metaphorical heights you are more than
okay with where you are at right here
right now and now you begin to feel very
warm and comfortable and you have a
sudden urge to sit down and relax for a
while the unhurried pace of your
movements matches the stone swaying seen
at a reggae concert you sit down and
rock back and forth you're at peace in
this idleness almost in a sedated state
of consciousness you misinterpret the
signs of this dangerous anomaly as a
sign of personal growth you believe
wholeheartedly that this is who you are
now and that this is who you are always
meant to be with newfound peace you
settle into the snow you embrace the
moment and that's when it gets even
worse
scp-1529 moves towards you navigating
the mountain with ease using just his
hands and feet no gear needed as its
arrival looms there is nothing you can
do but wait but what exactly are you
waiting for what's going on where did
this thing come from well you wouldn't
be the first to ask al the subject of
incident 1529-1 questioned this himself
elle was reportedly killed during an
encounter with
scp-1529 when it abruptly became active
shortly after he had reached the
mountain summit however elle was
eventually found alive when another team
reached his position nearly two days
later and removed him safely from the
mountain he required fingertip and toe
amputations due to frostbite but
otherwise made a full recovery while
still in the hospital an agent of the
foundation was able to ask him questions
and figure out what he had experienced
it was a difficult time for al but it
was an exciting time for the foundation
from what they previously understood of
scp-1529
they never thought they would hear the
truth straight from the victim's mouth
until then it was only ever told through
their autopsy elle was on his way down
the mountain he was proud and excited
having reached the top and accomplished
his life's goal but he understood the
trek back was no easier and that if he
didn't stay focused he would end up dead
like so many others he noticed his hood
was off and he sobbed to adjust it no
big deal just a quick fix little did l
know it would lead to such hardships
during his wardrobe malfunction his
group made their way about six meters
ahead of him and it was then standing in
his new found loneliness that he saw
scp-1529 coming over the ridge l was a
jovial fellow his impulse wasn't to fear
the figure instead he shouted and waved
assuming the figure to be another
climber left behind by his mates
suddenly it looked right at him and
that's when it started to happen elle
felt happy and relieved it was like all
the pain and the soreness and the chill
were gone no longer did he have blisters
on his feet he could feel his toes again
it was like he was back home in front of
the fireplace it was as if the journey
was complete and his efforts had been
rewarded elle no longer minded the
mission back down he felt perfectly fine
where he was but even still while his
body was content his gut didn't trust
the feeling something was off why would
l go all this way only to become
complacent he kept thinking he kept
fighting the urges to relax to succumb
to supposed feelings of warmth he knew
the stories of men who felt similar
misleading sensations when your body
starts to cool down to an extreme degree
your blood vessels dilate and you start
to feel like you're actually warming up
in these instances people often tear off
their clothes because they feel like
they are burning up and need to cool
down next thing they know they're naked
and frozen to death elle would not go
like that he had too much pride he tried
to shrug off the feelings of warmth but
before he even could it was stripped
from him as
scp-1529 got closer suddenly all the
heat and comfort l had experienced was
gone he was cold colder than he had ever
been before
his fingers and face no longer had
feeling his lips peeled snapped and
cracked they were frozen his legs
cramped up he buckled at the knees and
dropped into the snow he tried to yell
for help but all that came out was a
soft and pathetic whimper
scp-1529 grabbed elle's shoulders and
pulled him towards his face l looked
into his goggles having no other choice
he saw images in the lenses and suddenly
it was as if l was watching a film or
rather brief vignettes he saw people in
hot tubs relaxing a woman curled up by
an open fire a couple sunbathing on the
beach elle recognized all these warm and
happy people they were people he had
seen on the way up the mountain but not
the way down it only took a moment for
al to realize they were people who had
fallen to scp-1529
it was then l knew he had to resist but
scp-1529 doesn't take well to defiance
the images and the goggles changed from
happy to horror the same people were now
laying in the snow half dead elle
couldn't manage to look at it for
another second he balled his fist with
whatever strength god was willing to
lend him he tried to strike
scp-1529 in the goggles his arms moved
slowly at first like punching in a dream
it was moving as if the air it traveled
through was thick jello suddenly it
snapped into full speed and drilled
scp-1529
square in the center of his goggles
ultimately leading to el's rescue but
this is no princess movie not everyone
is so lucky to be rescued this brings us
back to you yes you wait you didn't
think that brief deviation from second
person would last forever did you so
where were we
or should i say
where were you
oh yes you're sitting in the snow
patiently waiting for scp-1529
to kill you and as you wait for its
arrival you think back to the survival
lessons that elle taught you now you can
see why i suddenly changed to third
person earlier so you're thinking of l
and how he punched scp-1529
and you're thinking you'll do the same
but what you can learn from al so
scp-1529 may have learned as well would
such a threatening creature ever be
defeated in the same way twice you
notice that its goggles have been
repaired and you intend on cracking them
open like an egg but your fist won't
close your arm won't raise you keep
trying to start up your strength like an
old pickup truck nothing your luck
eludes you you feel helpless and so you
sit in the snow and wait you can't ball
up your fingers into fists but you can
bring one palm to the other and pray you
pray for help from your god above your
prayers however are misguided yes there
is help above but it's not a god that's
watching over you but rather the
foundation's aerial surveillance a
well-oiled system of spyware born out of
necessity designed after the incident
known as scp-1529-2
scp-1529-2 occurred when an agent
located in a permanent facility in china
observed
scp-1529 through a telescope while it
was active near the summit of the
mountain that day
scp-1529 looked directly into the
telescope the agent immediately reported
symptoms consistent with an
scp-1529 encounter and reported that
scp-1529 had begun descending the
mountain in the direction of the
permanent facility similar to the
stories on the mountain the agent too
was unable to pull himself away from the
telescope after 17 minutes under the
spell of scp-1529
he was rushed to the facility sickbay
and found to have signs of frostbite in
the fingers and toes despite having
remained indoors for the duration of the
encounter the foundation then had to
rethink its approach to surveilling
scp-1529
when scp-1529 is active surveillance is
now conducted by means of an automated
telescope with a video feed playing at
seven seconds delay to avoid a repeat
incident of incident 1529-2
when necessary and safe additional
observation is done by way of helicopter
and airplane furthermore the bodies of
any hikers who encounter
scp-1529 are removed from the mountain
as soon as possible for autopsy and
disposal the foundation attributes all
scp-1529-related casualties to natural
causes relating to altitude sickness and
hypothermia any survivors or witnesses
are debriefed and administered a class b
amnestic and for even further safety
measures mobile task force
psy29029 also known as alpine echo
remains on standby at all times at the
foundation monitoring station in a
pressurized environment acclimatized to
7900 meters above sea level in the event
that a recurrence of incident 1529-1
occurs alpine echo deploys to the
mountain by helicopter and so by the
grace of the foundation
you will be saved although sitting
helplessly in the snow you may feel your
current state of existence can be best
described by the phrase dead meat you
are more than likely to be saved than
slaughtered even still there is no
comfort in the future on the mountain
right here right now you are looking up
and locking eyes with scp-1529
your whole life has come to this moment
all you ever wanted as a child was to
climb the highest heights aspiring
upward has brought you so many good
things adventures financial stability
respect everything you have in your life
is from the simple fact that you did not
settle for what you had but strived for
what was above you but now this same
impulse has gotten you in a world of
trouble had you just looked at where you
were instead of where you wanted to be
you would have been okay if you had just
felt the snow beneath your feet you
would have been okay but instead you
looked up how you always did you looked
up toward the goal and away from the
present and look where it has led you
the message of this story is clear but
if for some reason we resist the lesson
passed down from one generation of
thinkers to the next
scp-1529 is out there waiting for us to
turn over our shoulder and look back or
tilt our chin and look up and at that
point it will force the moral on you
again giving you no other option but to
experience its wrath
right here
right now
now go check out frozen bodies on
everest r live
scp-5140 and scp-096 killed my friend
for more high-altitude horrors